we're trapped pardon me excuse me did
you say we're trapped who the hell are
you you don't recognize Carolyn Saint
Jack Renard the associate principal
cellist for the Berlin Philharmonic
she's my surprise celebrity are you
kidding me you ruined my big goodbye to
the 99 so we could listen to some nerd
play a giant violin oh shall I begin no
wait wait did you say your goodbye to
the 99
where you going
well
I was hoping that this would be a more
dramatic moment accompanied by fireworks
but
I'm leaving the NYPD you are what
seriously for real yeah today was my
last day and now it looks like it's
gonna end with all of us locked in a
storage facility
no it's not can't you see you all want
the same thing a perfect goodbye but
you're all getting in each other's way
we are the nine nine
and we work best together and we're
getting out of here together so we're
gonna find that too and we're gonna be
Crown Grand champions of the nine nine
together except for the ugly one that
made fun of my cello not now Carolyn
Saint Jacques Renard I agree with
Jeffrey read the room Carolyn Saint
Jacqueline great speech Terry but we're
kind of Trapped in here not for long
I'm gonna Kool-Aid manners the hell out
of here I thought you said that
was not I just find it demeaning it's
actually very easy
[Music]
now go through that wall I'm not doing
any more walls Jake we're free fair
enough I had to ask sorry captain no you
guys brought Hitchcock uh no we just
bumped into him in the lobby we don't
know why he's here Kenny baby I love
what prison is doing to your figure
okay
so how's prison nobody likes cops in
here so I don't earn their Respect by
starting a bunch of riots who got
through on solitary for a week what's
going on with your face
I hate seeing you like this so I'm
flexing my eyes real hard to keep from
crying it's okay we can still have a
normal conversation so how's the food
pay no attention to him Rosa he's very
emotional Rosa why are you saying my
first name wow Rosa I read an article in
the medical journal that said one
destabilizing aspect of the
incarceration is the constant
dehumanization Rosa you need to be
reminded that you're more than just a
number Rosa you are Rosa
Rosa yep that fixes prison is there
anything we can do to help you anything
you need done on the outside no I'm good
it's not a problem Rosa we're here for
you Rosa whatever you need Rosa
we've got some great opening lines here
three very reasonable explanations as to
why you don't want to go to Canada and
four very attractive options for your
invitation card stock well I like
romantic opening C uh this page about
how my life is New York and I love the
Chantilly ecru paper for Place cards
that is an excellent choice those are
all excellent choices you can do this
you're a smart and wonderful man with
fantastic handwriting share with
fantastic handwriting you really think
so yeah I think that you could be a
professional calligrapher Charles
a professional calligrapher you can do
anything including but not limited to
talking to Vivian right right right
look I know it's gonna be hard and she
might even get mad at you but I promise
you'll be back to doing weird sex stuff
together in no time
all right all right
I'm gonna go talk to Vivi great idea
buddy
ah yep yeah
so who's gonna pay for the paper it's
going to be 250 dollars
her name is Amy Santiago so here are
your puzzles from the daisy arsonist at
the fires this is really good Amy thanks
hey so then uh just curious would you
say you have the typical physique of a
puzzle maker or well each puzzle only
pays a couple hundred bucks so I mostly
make my money modeling primarily
swimwear yeah I hear that I could do
that too but I make pretty good money
here so don't really need to anyways
let's talk about the case so here's a
letter that the arsonist sent to then
your Clues I discombobulate to teach you
to conjugate the fool who fails to
validate will watch as I conflagrate it
seems like it's using my crossword to
tell me something oh maybe we should
look at anagrams of the answers that's
really good old nasty Amiga
jerk pal
I said that phrase I really think this
anagram approach makes a lot of sense
seriously let's do it I'll tell
you great and
after coffee but I love a kombucha great
I'll just walk to the kombucha store
everything okay
of course
wear a coat over a tank you're not Ryan
Gosling I'm feeling jealous buddy no not
at all I mean I am a little surprised
that somebody named Melvin is so
Bodacious but I feel that jealousy is an
ugly emotion that you were feeling and
I'm just glad that Amy's spending some
time with her hero who's super hot
Charles Let It Go and smart I'm serious
stop
and hilarious
eat a jerk pal so how's it going in here
man I see you're still coatless I run
hot like a wolf oh I see I wonder if the
word conjugate in the arsonist letter
means we should focus on the verb
answers cool I love verbs second
favorite part of speech after
prepositions uh yeah words are cool but
maybe we should switch gears a bit and
get back to some good old-fashioned
police work what are you thinking well
whoever said in these fires is clearly
trying to humiliate Finn you know make a
puzzle you can't solve so maybe we
should focus on people that don't like
you Jake has a point about motive maybe
another Puzzler wants to take you down
well if you're looking for a puzzle head
I'm hosting a crossword night at the
turnkey bar tonight oh I've always
wanted to go there that place is a total
puzz hang
all right so we'll go undercover chat
some people up and see if we can't find
our arsonist good idea oh Amy likes my
plan great so then why don't we just get
this coat back on you and I'll help you
get out of the door here and we'll see
you tonight okay bye
the best right yeah
we brought her in this morning and she
confessed immediately hi van I love you
did you see my fires turned out she was
writing something specifically marry me
or else I will kill you yours forever
Helen gorbelson wow so many fires so
many fires thank you for catching her
with a brilliant puzzling mind like
yours on the case it was only a matter
of time actually Jake solved it he's
kind of a genius with this stuff oh
thank you then couldn't have done it
without your help so I guess that's that
I should probably run if I'm going to
make it to the Javits Center by four
they're making a mold of me for the
upcoming Bodies exhibit as they should
your body is great and that's okay
thanks man you should join me for a
puzzle night sometime no
Jake is taken he already has a friend
hang offer decline now let's try your
centerfold ass out of here
I mean
see it I think it's amazing oh Jake and
Amy and baby makes three I don't know if
I believe in God but I have prayed for
this that is psychotic all right Ames
let's go over your cover story again
okay my name is Isabel Cortez I'm in for
murder because some perv on the subway
tried to touch me and I was like did
someone order tracheotomy okay I think
that's a little too technical we need to
work on your tough talk so what are you
in for Cortez none of your damn business
nice keep going with that I'm gonna
split you like a Sunday with Grandpa
okay I think the part was
great yeah although mean threats
generally don't involve having desserts
with your grandparents so just try again
keep telling me what to do and I'll stab
your face off oh yes
okay now here's the plan instead of you
approaching Maura we're gonna get her to
come to you yeah try and spread the word
that you've got to connect on the
outside that gives you access to
contraband cigarettes burner phones
pornography Emmy women don't watch
they do oh yeah oh wow yeah well that's
an exciting Revelation for me huh